d'abord en avril dernier santé canada
s'est discrètement ranger derrière
l'organisation mondiale de la santé en
modifiant sa directive sur les risques
liés à l'exposition de l'amiante
puis pratiquement au même moment on
apprenait dans une simple note de
service que l'utilisation de l'amiante
serait désormais interdite par certains
ministères fédéraux canadiens cette
décision n'était pas étrangère aux
résultats d'une enquête menée deux mois
plus tôt par sybille si radio canada
kerri mise à jour une liste incomplète
de plus de 100 bâtiments du gouvernement
à ottawa dans la capitale contaminées
par de l'amiante c'est une annonce
majeure pour nous parce que ici dans la
région on parle quand même d'un parc
immobilier assez important on parle de
gréement de parcs canada pêches et
océans et que je te vois les tous les
immeubles qui appartiennent aux autres
ministères et agences comme l' agence du
revenu du canada denis saint jean
responsable de la santé de la sécurité à
l'alliance de la fonction publique du
canada
le principal syndicat des fonctionnaires
du gouvernement canadien on était quand
même agréablement surpris lors de 2
février ou en répondant à une question
de la critique du travail chez rue
bensen sur justement l'utilisation de
l'amiante dans les édifices fédéraux
la ministre des services publics et
approvisionnement madame judy foote ont
répondu qu'elle faisait un examen
complet et que l'utilisation de
l'amiante serait sérieusement considérer
ou tout au moins pour continuer sur une
base continue on été agréablement
surpris denis lapointe est un
électricien il a appris comme des
centaines d'autres travailleurs et
fonctionnaires qu'ils avaient été
exposés à de l'amiante et à d'autres
toxines pendant cinq ans alors qu'ils
travaillaient à l' agence du revenu du
canada à ottawa sera pas bien mon
sommeil tout dérangé ou stockage 3 4 aux
je peux m'en pour planifier avec ma
famille parce que je sais pas chez red
bull mais depuis une vingtaine d'années
le débat faisait rage au canada
débat entre spécialistes entre ceux
souvent payés par les compagnies
d'extraction de l'amiante qui affirmait
que le produit n'était pas dangereux
pour la santé et d'autres scientifiques
indépendants cela qui affirmait que les
dangers très réels qu'en fait un
travailleur canadien sur trois qui
tombent malades
mais en relation directe avec son
exposition à l'amiante
le manager avec 7,7 amiante et peut
s'écouler de v1 40 ans entre
l'exposition aux fibres et l'apparition
de la maladie
dog angus et professeur à l'école de
gestion telfer et il est expert en
économie de la santé et en politique de
la santé mais je pense que la chose
qu'on devrait faire c'est de vraiment
complètement détruire ces six équipes
essaient de faire d'autres édifices cent
des produits l'amiante
oui oui si on fait pas de rénovation à
moins de risques mais si un risque avec
sept produits
on est vrai qu'on peut faire que
l'avenir maintenant pour l'amiante les
régions au canada qui dépendait de son
extraction se sont posé la question au
fur et à mesure que les cinq grandes
mines du pays ont fermé tour à tour
leurs portes
la dernière en 2011 au québec il existe
des projets maintenant afin de
réutiliser les résidus d'amiante
on a créé littéralement autour des mines
de véritables montagnes de résidus des
montagnes de slag comme disent les
mineurs qui contiennent un déchet rare
aujourd'hui précieux du magnésium
or la compagnie allianz magnésium
prévoit au québec toujours fabriqué ces
premiers lingots en janvier 2017 grâce à
son projet pilote sur le site d'une
ancienne mine pour savoir que le canada
a été un des producteurs principal
d'avion pour des détenus qui étaient
peut-être certains moments et des
avantages pourraient peut-être
transformé en une grande opportunité
le docteur joël fournier et président et
chef de la direction d'allianz magnésium
formation appropriée peut créer des
produits de très haute dans la rejeter
le magnésium est un métal stratégique
qui est utilisé dans une foule
d'applications entre autres dans les
alliages d'aluminium on parle beaucoup
de la croissance de l'e millions dans le
domaine des transports
l'aluminium est utilisé sous forme
d'alliages qui peut contenir jusqu'à 5%
de magnésium donc c'est pas négligeable
en terme de quantité aussi le magnésium
est aussi tunisie directement dans les
transports
hors automobile elles utilisent beaucoup
pour certaines pièces de composants que
ce soit les moulins les colonnes de
direction autres pierres sur des
véhicules qui sont faits avec ce métal
toujours pour but d'alléger ou de bbc
les propriétés exceptionnelles de ce
métal il ya donc une vie après l'amiante
il ya des possibilités il ya des projets
personnes magnésium un talent pour moi
de l'entreprise dans ses coins treasure
l'a dit mercier et chercheur spécialiste
de la restauration du site et de la
gestion des matières dangereuses au
centre eau terre environnement l inrs à
québec
elle a d'ailleurs toutes les tailles des
tailles fines et détaillées recherche
avec des blocs de 200 kg 300 kilos à une
tonne et puis c'est pas de l'amiante
défilent capes de magnésium qu'on peut
transformer que ça des produits comme ça
peut même servir pour faire capter le
co2 acheminer des aciéries des
cimenteries des choses comme ça dans la
lutte aux changements climatiques donc
une sorte de chose qui peut être fait au
niveau industriel c'est pour un problème
avec de travailler avec renault
un reportage de radio canada
international